[Música]
quero avisar as câmeras que eu tô
bebendo na boca porque essa garrafa
minha tá antes que alguém dá para tirar
educado cara eu não conto tipo vejo um
cara que
e dele ou com ele
não tem que botar seis restaurante
[Música]
pelo jeito aí vamos ver a batida
na orelha dela foi
aí pelo menos na pia dá para nós ganhar
viu
Bota a mão galerinha
pelo amor de Deus
não sabe jogar bola
[Aplausos]
tá sendo professor
sair com a Vitória Mas deixamos bons
irmãozinho aí mano
na Bahia e a pelada né em Sampa
Crew
Nathan gosta de agredir eu não sei o que
é isso O negócio é que é igual lutador
que ganha só no primeiro rádio nós tem
que fazer logo os três porque depois
difícil
[Aplausos]
[Música]
olha o gol de Lux sem compromisso aí
patrão
ovo
eu quero eu quero cuscuz
Eu quero
tudo só não quero só não quero cebola
você que tiver uma batata maior que essa
mande um Direct para mim que eu mando um
pi na mesma hora de r$ 50 mas tem que
ser ama eu aqui é essa aqui
[Música]
Valeu boa noite
vai vai para mim aqui então
[Música]
Eu quero saber quem foi que fez xixi no
chão sem que tem a fralda vai limpar
pode limpar eu não tenho pregado
que é um telefone aí ó
réplica do telefone usado por Dom Pedro
aí era o original encontra-se no Acervo
do Museu Imperial isso aí não vou nem
tocar se eu não me engano era o processo
que a galera morria a cana botava a cana
aqui ó
e os bois ficava rodando Moinho na cama
andaram mijando aqui quem foi foi tu
Regina carroceiro só tem um braço mas
também o boi só tem um chifre
Alô
[Música]
descarregou galera mas aí eu já coloquei
ele no carregador galera descarregou a
câmera mas não vou deixar o vídeo sem
final não clique em gostei aí tô
querendo fazer nos próximos vídeos uma
paradinha para poder trazer alguém para
passar um dia com a gente hein o dia com
a tropinha do W vai lá no meu Twitter
onde eu postei esse vídeo divulgando e
deixa um RT que eu quero ver se tem
muita gente interessado você via Até nós
participar com a gente e aparecer aqui
no canal rapado né me ajuda aí Major
clique em gostei e comente aqui que que
você achou e o que que você pensa para
eu poder ter mais ideia para colocar
mais coisa legal aqui para você tamo
junto até amanhã beijo